Do what is meaningful,
not what is expedient.
And when you do what is meaningful,
you stay in the kingdom that you've
established,
but you don't stay completely in it
because you need to challenge yourself
and grow.
And so you put one foot tentatively out
into the domain that supersedes your
competence and you maintain stability
and grow at the same time.
And when you're doing that properly,
then the f psychological consequences of
that is the immersement in a meaningful
experience.
It's a deep instinct.
So when you know,
if you watch yourself,
you say,
well,
I had a particularly good day at work
and what does that mean?
Well,
it means that you lost your sense of
time,
right?
Because when you're having not a good
day at work,
it's like first it's one minute to three
and then it's
45 seconds to three,
and then it's 30 seconds.
That's what school was like for me.
It was like
click.
So funny.
You know,
I went to,
I went to my daughter's school,
I used to get in trouble for talking all
the time.
Surprise,
surprise when I was a kid and uh,
and I was bored stiff in school and so I
would misbehave upon occasion out of
pure boredom.
And about 21 years ago,
I went to my daughter's school to sit
for a class.
It was about an hour long and uh,
I was sitting there and the teacher had
all the kids on the floor and was having
some of the kids read to the others and
some of the kids who were reading
couldn't read at all.
And I had exactly the same experience.
I was sitting there,
it was like being,
it's like being seven years old again
and I could see the clock going,
tick,
tick.
And I thought,
you know,
if I was in this classroom for three
days,
I would misbehave,
fit 40 years old,
I would miss behave exactly like I did
when I was when I was six.
No,
well that's no place to be right because
that's,
you don't want to be in a place that
stultifying you don't want to be in a
place where there's no challenge.
You might even quit your job if there's
no challenge.
Say,
well that's a good job.
It gives you security and you think,
God,
I can't stand this.
It's eating away at my soul.
It's all security and no challenge.
So why do you want a challenge?
Cause that's what you're built for.
That's what you're built for.
Your built to take on a maximal load,
right?
Cause that's what strengthens you.
And you need to be strong because life
is extraordinarily difficult.
And because the evil king is always
whittling away at the structure of the
state and you have to be awake and sharp
to stop that from happening so that you
don't become corrupt and so that your
family doesn't become corrupt.
And so that your state doesn't have to
be come become corrupt.
You have to have your eyes open and your
which sharp and your words at the ready.
And you have to be educated and you have
to know about your history.
And you know how have to know how to
think.
And you have to know how to read and you
have to know how to speak.
And you have to know how to aim.
And you have to be willing to hoist the
troubles of the world up on your
shoulders.
And what's so interesting about that,
so remarkable,
and this is something that's really
manifested itself to me as I've been
doing these public lectures.
I've been talking about responsibility
to people,
which doesn't seem to happen very often
anymore,
and the audiences are dead quiet.
And I lay out this idea that life is
tragedy tainted by malevolence and
everyone says,
yeah,
well we already always suspected that,
but no one has ever said it quite so
bluntly,
and it's quite a relief to hear that I'm
not the only person who has those
suspicions.
And then the second part of that is the
better part,
and it's the optimistic part,
which is despite the fact that life is a
tragedy tainted by malevolence at every
level of existence,
there's something about the human spirit
that can thrive under precisely those
conditions if we allow that to occur.
Because as difficult as life is and as
horrible as we are,
our capacity to deal with that
catastrophe and to transcend that
malevolent spirit is more powerful than
the,
than that reality itself.
And that's the fundamental issue.
I think that's the fundamental issue of
the Judaeo Christian ethic with its
emphasis on the divinity of the
individual.
As catastrophic as life is and as
malevolent as people can be.
And that's malevolent beyond belief.
Fundamentally,
a person has in spirit the nobility to
set that right and to defeat evil and
that and that more than that and that
the antidote to the catastrophe of life
and the suffering of life and the
tragedy of life that can drive you down
and destroy you,
is to take on exactly that
responsibility and to say,
well,
there's plenty of work to be done and
isn't that terrible and there isn't
anything so bad that we can't make it
worse and certainly try very hard to do
so.
But I have it within me to decide that
I'm going to stand up against that.
I'm going to strive to make the world a
better place.
I'm going to strive to constrain the
malevolence that's in my own heart and
to set my family's straight and to work,
to work despite my tragic lot for the
betterment of anything,
of everything that's in front of me.
And the consequence of that,
the immediate consequence of that is
that when you make the decision to take
on all of that voluntarily,
which is to stand up straight,
by the way,
with your shoulders back,
to take on that,
all that on voluntarily,
as soon as you make that decision,
then all the catastrophe justifies
itself in the nobility of your striving.
And that's what it means to be an
individual.
Thank you.
[inaudible].